اوبريت نينوى مشروع فني عراقيه متكامل
يهدف الى احياء التراث الحضاري والفلكيري
لمحافظه نينوى المشروع يستهدفوا فئه
المجتمع في المحافظه المعروفه بتنوعها
الثقفي والفني واللغوي وغنائها الحضاري
والاثار عبر التاريخ ويحاول مشروع
التركيز على الابداع الشباب الذي يساهم
فيه بشكل كبير في تنظيمه وتقديمه للجمهور
ويدخل القائمون على المشروع في تحدي مع
الفنانين كاظم الساهر ورحم رياض في
الفيديو الذي سيكون لاكثر من 30 دقيقه
والذي يتمنى منتجوه ان يصبح ايقونه
لمحافظه نينوى
يا ليلى والنور
يا مهدل الحضارات
يا ملتقى الورسلي مثلك ما صار احميكي
ما صار
[موسيقى]
بسيطه
تضرب
[موسيقى]
من المصلين
ويونس ابراهيم يسعد صباحك يا يونس نتحدث
اولا على فكره المشروع والهدف منه
صباح الخير على برنامج صباح العربيه من
العراق
[موسيقى]
لكل المكونات اللي موجودين في محافظه
قبل شهرين
انتشر على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
من قبل شهرين زمان
ولا قصد الجميع نعم يونس فعلا البرومو
راقي
وتشويقي لهذا الابريت الغنائي لكن التحدي
لفنانين معروفين على الاوساط العربيه
والعالميه ايضا كاظم الساهر ورحم رياض
لماذا
نحنا هذا العمل
تطوعي كل المشتركين والفنانين اللي شاركوا
بهذا العمل يعني بشكل تطوعي او قريتي
العمل مهما لقينا من الدعم من جهه ااه
يعني دعم لهذا العمل على مستوى كبير ومهما
تعبنا على العمل همم احنا بدنا نرتقي هذا
العمل الى مستوى اقل شيء الوطن العربي
النجوم اللي اختارناهم
الاستاذ كاظم الساهر
هم هجوم على مستوى العالم اصبحوا الان
يعني المقطع الفيديو او الصور اللي تنتشر
عنهم
اختيار لانهم لانهم بالتاكيد يمثلوا
العراق
احسن تمثيل ويشرفنا انه يكونوا يعني بهذا
العمل
يعني فيها اشتراك لكن هل في تكسيف لهذا
الهاشتاج هل في محاولات للوصول اليهم من
خلال مقربين لهم او جهات معينه
طبعا كل تاكيد يعني الصفحات الصفحات
العراقيه على السوشيال ميديا بالاخص
الانستقرام
كثير من الاشخاص ادعموني بالحمله بترتيب
الهاشتاج القيصر
الرياض امثال همم
مشاهير العراق همم ايضا معي اصدقائي
ادعموني جدا الكبير بالنسبه
اها طب يونس بما انه انت الناشط ومنتج هذا
المشروع نتمنى ان توجه تتوجه الى الكاميرا
من خلال برنامج صباح العربيه وتوجه كلمتك
مباشره لكاظم الساهر ورحم رياض
يعني
وانما حب لهم يعني اليوم نحن بنختارناهم
انه يشاركون بهذا الاخرين بالتاكيد بدنا
نقول لهم فنانين عراقيين هذا البلد همم
وهم على مين يعني انا ارسل لهم تحيات همم
مدينه الموصل
وادعوهم انه يوافقون على هذه الدعوه اللي
ارسلناها لهم همم
واتمنى انه يكون همم النساء همم هذا العمل
التطوع اللي همم يحمل همم
مش عارفين فيه همم كثير من الفنانين اللي
مرموقين هذا المستوى المحافظه لو جاءوا
لهم قبل فيديوهات اخرى سيكون هذا العمل ان
شاء الله همم
طيب وحتى من دون هذا الدعم يونس تتمنون ان
يتحول مشروع نينوى الى ايقونه لمحافظه
نينوى بشكل عام على اي اساس على ماذا
تركزون في هذا العمل ليتحول الى يقول
المحافظه هي عباره عن يعني
مليئه بالمكونات يعني كل مكون يتكلم لغه
لغه تختلف عن المكون الاخر ويرتدون ايضا
ازياء في الفلوريه تختلف عن المكون الان
نحن مره
من جرائم ارهابيه خصوصا مع همم يعني داعش
فاصبحت الفكره انه محافظه
همم يعني همم الافكار اليوم هذا الاخرين
بحياتك نظره جدا عن هذه المحافظه ما يحمله
همم فنانين كبار على مستوى جدا كبير همم
وما يحملهم من همم افكار همم
التراث اللي موجود عندنا في المحافظه التي
تعرفين ان احنا عندنا همم حضاره همم جدا
همم قديمه وعريقه هذه حضاره حضاره عاشور
العمل هو راح يركز على الترا اللي موجود
في المحافظه الازياء الفلوريه اللي موجود
في كل مكون تنوع الجندر ما بين الدكتور
والمكون همم
هذا انا قلت انه يعني يدخلوني اياه انا
هجوم على مستوى العراق بيغنون ايضا
باللهجه المصلاويه النهج المصليه عفوا همم
لحتى يبرز بشكل المغاير ويلاقي صداع هذا
العمل يعني اما اذا احنا بشكل محلي للاسف
كل
التعبئه على مستوى سنتين
بالتوفيق يونس نتمنى ان تصل دعوتكم شكرا
لكم من الموصل ناشط منتج مشروع بريث نينوى
يونس ابراهيم